the northeast of england has many
reminders of the government's records
since the coronavirus pandemic began
the scandals and the successes that
voters might judge them on
like barnard castle for example boris
johnson's former top advisor dominic
cummings
infamously broke lockdown to come here
on a trip he refused to apologize for
but it's also home to a big medicines
facility part of the government's highly
effective vaccination program
the northeast is a brick in the
so-called red wall
the belt of former industrial
constituencies that until recently
historically voted for the labour party
in 2019
many switched to the conservatives
helping serve boris johnson
a landslide victory hartlepool didn't
but it might on thursday amidst all
england's council and mayoral elections
hart lepaul alone has a by-election for
a member of
parliament not anyone's guess at the
minute as to where it might go
three-time hartlepool mayor stuart
drummond knows the town as well as
anyone
he cautions against only seeing the
by-election as a referendum on how the
conservative government's handled
covid19
i think what people want more than
anything is someone who's going to
represent
the town represent them represent um
and really talk the town up fight down
at westminster
for the good of the town you know
there's inequalities in health
in the economy poverty you'll name it
local issues loom large here cuts during
the last decade have stripped the
hospital of his accident in emergency
unit
other services have disappeared too many
observers say
it's this feeling of being left behind
that is the reason why brexit was so
popular
in the post-industrial north the labour
party now
struggles to convince voters here that
it's not just the voice of the remainer
metropolitan south
a generational shift in voting has swept
through other northern communities
is it hartlepool's turn to fall to the
tories
for labour to vanish completely
and be just unthinkable i i can't see it
happening
i suspect conservatives will win here
because that's how the general
picture seems to be going across the
country especially looking at the last
elections i'm
still unsure we've got that much stuff
being sent through the post
i'm a little bamboozled by all of the
different candidates that's going to be
fair
also a bit bamboozled is tom brooks the
law and government professor says
kovid19 has made it hard to predict
where many of the country's myriad local
elections are going
i do think hartley pool will be likely
to stay
labor in the end but i think it is
difficult because the normal rules that
political analysts would have as to how
things would turn out
looking at campaigning looking at you
know how people how effective people
been out on the stump
reactions to messages on those in the
street when it's hard to find people on
the street you can't really get too
close
barnard castle's walls started crumbling
in the 1500s
labour will be hoping its own period of
decline is shorter
and that its political walls can be
rebuilt
rory challenge al jazeera the north east
of england